this is actually super interesting to me
because it's one of the most famous
proofs of all time it's the uh the proof
for for mars last theorem which andrew
wiles famously solved now i don't want
to explain that all i want to explain is
what's at the heart
of that proof it's actually not
what while spent seven years on it's
actually something else it's the
taniyama shimura wild conjecture which
is now called modularity so what we're
going to say is for mars last theorem is
true
and it has to be just as obvious as the
fact that one doesn't equal two in this
case for mars last theorem reduces down
to something called modularity
it's the modularity theorem so it's not
one one doesn't equal two here it's
something else so it's all it's about
two things so it's about uh er elliptic
curves and this is four specifically for
whole numbers
and fractions are actually
modular forms in disguise so
what does that mean and that's how i
feel even as a mathematician it's like
what
so what i want to do today is just
trying to get you to appreciate
what this means just an appreciation
not the full thing just an appreciation
of what's going on and what i'm going to
do is i'm just going to use much
simpler equations right what do you want
to start with so starting with modular
forms a modular form
now the way you need to think about this
is it's something to do with symmetry
but there's different forms of symmetry
okay and the one i want to show you
today is called translational symmetry
and what it is is this is imagine you
have like an infinite plane this was
this is being nicely provided by brown
paper and imagine we actually have here
so i'm just gonna just gonna kind of
like
just put like arrows to represent that
i've chopped this up
imagine now cutting this up into strips
infinite strips but the important thing
is is that the strips are all the same
width and so now
something has the symmetry as the
translational symmetry because this goes
on forever
like left and right okay so you can
imagine like this kind of situation what
has the symmetry which you can basically
take a strip of this and cut and paste
but what's important is we want to know
what functions
you can cut and paste cut paste yeah a
graph but what it is we're looking for
an equation we want something to
generate it because
say if you had like a picture of a funny
picture in here it might have a really
complicated equation um maybe it doesn't
even have an equation at all like if you
think about a pattern i mean this
doesn't even have regular pattern my
shirt i usually like pretty regular
pattern shirts but the point is i just
want to show you something which
actually has a very regular pattern and
it's something you i'm hoping you've
seen before
it's one of these things
but basically this is
a sine wave so it goes up and down up
and down up and down now this actually
has a long complicated equation but the
important thing is it's like even though
it is this equation that you crank out
potentially you could cut and paste cut
and paste cut and paste so that's the
idea a modular form has that except it's
hyperbolic geometry and it's really
complicated
but if you get the if you just
appreciate the fact that it's a cut and
paste thing you take one section of it
you cut paste cut and paste that's the
idea
now not all functions are like that how
about a function like this that's my
attempt at a circle
thanks man so a circle
has an equation i'm actually going to
write the equation down just because
it's fun basically the circle okay is
another equation except it doesn't have
translational symmetry think about it it
just exists in one section so
what this relationship is saying
elliptic curves are whole numbers and
fractions uh modular forms in disguise
it's actually saying
that you can fit
a modular form into elliptic curve you
can fit
a translational symmetry equation into
the equation of the circle that's what
it's saying this is magical stuff so the
so how does this work how can we make
this work
well the way you have to think about it
is that
imagine now we had a point on the circle
all right and now we start following it
around here
so you know let's just have fun maybe we
could do it really quickly go around
really quickly or maybe go slowly maybe
go fast slow fast slow fast low
but if we chose to do it
at a constant rate yeah going round and
around and around imagine what that
looked like if this was actually moving
through space
so if you think about it if i'm doing
the circle
imagine now if i go like this so now i'm
going to start moving
at the same rate as i'm going up
and so what's actually going on is i'm
actually making a coil
like a slinky it's like a slinky that's
right so now just imagine right what
we're doing is we're actually creating a
coil now again if it was a slinky you
know how slinkies you can like make them
bunched up and but imagine we've got a
slinky that's just perfectly evenly
spaced here okay
so now that has an equation that has a
it's
like a helix equation it's got an
equation in 3d
but what happens if you look down the
barrel of that helix
what would you see like if you looked
straight down and there was no
perspective problems like if you look
straight down the barrel what would you
see a circle that's right
so what's actually going on there is
that
the helix can fit inside the equation of
the circle
and the only reason this works is
because
3d space and 2d space are both flat
when you're dealing with curvy spaces
this is really not an option and these
are curvy spaces the actual
elliptic curves belongs to projective
space
martial forms belongs to hyperbolic
space the complex numbers i mean they
are really super curvy but in this
example it's really nice because what
we're doing is we're actually fitting
three-dimensional numbers
into two-dimensional numbers not really
three-dimensional they exist in
three-dimensional but you've got to
think that there's a different
relationship going on so what the coil
has the coil has translational symmetry
so
this is the link between modular forms
and elliptic curves
it says
that
this really strange function over here
can fit inside this really dull function
over here and when this happened no one
believed it no one believed you could
stick you know you can stick this coil
into the circle the reason why no one
believed it was because no one could
visualize it so nicely like we can
because as i said they're completely
different spaces that's the connection
that needed to happen to actually make
for mars last theorem work
it's this is again this is not the real
thing
because if you think about it if you
have a whole number or a fraction as
it's cycling around okay as long as it's
a fraction there will be a point where
it will come back on top of itself like
there's a point where fractions because
there's a number you can multiply a
fraction by you'll get a whole number so
what that means is in turning around a
circle if you start with some sort of
fraction
you'll end up back at the same spot but
if you have an irrational number which
by definition is something that can't be
a fraction
if you started at some point and went
around by root two
you'll never get back to the to the
actual original position
so again this is the feeling here of the
proof
the fact that these these numbers matter
so the type of number matters this is
not how the proof is works i again i'm
trying to give you a feeling for what's
going on the fact that the reason why
for mars last theorem involves numbers
is because these numbers the way the
numbers are actually they work together
impact
whether you can put a curve into one of
these and so then how they linked it in
here is the fact that they said for mars
last theorem involves whole numbers
therefore the circle
equation i'm making should permit one of
these things
except they proved all these wonderful
people that you've seen on number file
and you should be seeing if you haven't
seen yet all the wonderful people
actually proved this they showed that
that created a contradiction so
basically even though you're playing by
the rules and using whole numbers
using whole numbers not even fractions
whole numbers
it doesn't permit one of these things so
again it's the one not equaling two
our thanks to audible.com for supporting
this number file video they've got
something like 180 000 spoken word
titles in their collection and i often
enjoy listening to well just a few of
them on my daily dog walks here with the
girls now if the beauty of mathematics
is something you like why don't you try
love and math the hidden heart of
reality it's by edward frenkel someone
you've probably seen in quite a few
number five videos already it's got all
sorts of great stuff in it including
quite a lot about famar's last theorem
it's something that's not a million
miles from professor frankel's own
research and like so many books it's
available in audio form at audible so go
to audible.com number file if you'd like
to give it a try or when you sign on for
their free one month trial you might
choose a different book from their
extensive collection there are plenty of
math ones i can assure you of that
that address again audible.com number
file so they know you came from here
and as a very happy audible user myself
i'd like to thank them for supporting
this video